when i think about the traditional
modalities around healthcare
you know one thing i'm pretty certain
we're not going to look kindly on
years from now is the myopic
perspective on lifestyle diet nutrition
all of these things that are the key
contributors to
the real um epidemics of our time
which are the chronic lifestyle
illnesses that are killing more people
than anything else right now and the
over-medication of everybody
the treatment of symptoms the inability
to really get to the underlying
causes and to you know address those in
a meaningful way
a major component of integrative
medicine is lifestyle medicine
and i think that puts us in a really
strong position to offer real preventive
advice to people
uh the total instruction i got in
nutrition at four years in four years at
harvard medical school was 30 minutes
which we're grudging hasn't changed much
no it hasn't changed much
and when nutrition is taught it's taught
as biochemistry which is forgotten as
soon as the biochemistry exams are over
uh so you know i think most most doctors
are functionally illiterate in nutrition
unless they've made an effort to
to learn it on their own which is not so
easy to do yeah well systemically
the education is not about it's not
about
preventing disease or the promotion of
well-being it's about the treatment
of disease in fact that was one of my
motivations for getting out and learning
other methods was
i had learned nothing about health and
healing in my medical studies
you know i hardly ever heard the word
healing used and it always seemed to me
the main job my main job was to teach
people how not to get sick in the first
place and i hadn't learned how to do
that
um so let's define
integrative medicine well the short
definition is it's the intelligent
combination of conventional medicine
and natural and preventive medicine and
the alternate selected use of
alternative therapies but i think you
know the
fuller definition is it's a system that
really focuses on the body's
ability to heal itself that looks at
people as whole persons
not just physical bodies that takes all
aspects of lifestyle into account
that values the practitioner-patient
relationship
and makes use of all available
treatments no matter where they come
from as long as they're not going to
hurt people and show
reasonable evidence of efficacy and how
does that differ from
functional medicine you know functional
medicine there's some overlap between
functional medicine and integrative
medicine but i think they're quite
different
uh i think that that functional medicine
is very focused on biochemical
mechanisms
i think overly focused on that and and
some of those biochemical mechanisms i
think may not have great clinical
relevance and then
in practice the the treatment is
correcting these
these functional biochemical
disturbances
by recommending a lot of of supplements
to take
i think that functional medicine is has
much less emphasis on mind-body medicine
on
spirituality and medicine on the
community aspects of medicine
so i think i personally think that
integrative medicine is a
more comprehensive more robust system so
in the training of this next generation
of integrative
medicine practitioners um
the challenge you know there's there's a
lot of challenges but
not the least of which is what is the
business model because you're budding up
against a conventional system that's
driven by you know insurance
reimbursement by profit
right yeah exactly yeah you know as
dysfunctional as our health care system
in this is and it's very dysfunctional
it's generating rivers of money and that
money is flowing into very few
pockets it's the pockets of the big
pharmaceutical companies the
manufacturers of medical devices
the big insurers and the big health care
you know uh
corporations and those vested interests
don't want anything to change
you know they're making out like like
bandits and i feel bad we
we train the people that come to us you
know really highly and then we turn them
out in the world where everything's
stacked against them
you know the priorities of reimbursement
are backward you know we don't
we don't pay a doctor to sit with a
patient and teach a breathing exercise
we pay a doctor to prescribe drugs
um to and often when the doctor doesn't
think those are necessary or to do tests
you know we don't we don't reimburse for
lifestyle
counseling right so that all has to
change
[Music]
you